معنى حول هذا الموضوع الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي اللواء فايز الدويري اللواء
فايز الدويري كيف يمكن تفسير هذا الجدل
القائم حول مدينه هذه المدينه الصغيره
التي يعني قال اكثر من طرف خلال هذه الحرب
بانها لا تحمل اهميه استراتيجيه وانما
اهميه رمزيه يتم الحديث عنها
لا هي في الواقع لها اهميه استراتيجيه ولا
اهميه رميه اهميه الاستراتيجيه هي عقده
مواصلات السكك الحديديه والطرق المعبده
وبالتالي السيطره عليها تمنح القوات
المهاجمه فرصه التقدم على الطرق الرئيسيه
الى سلافيان
وبالتالي هي لها قيمه الاستراتيجيه ولكن
القرار السياسي
حدد اليه المعركه
وظروف المعركه وطالب بالاستمرار واعتبرها
رمزا للصمود في ظل ضبابيه المشهد وتضخيم
الانجازات من جانب الجانب الروسي
وتضخيم القدرات من الجانب الاوكراني لابد
للذهاب الى مصدر محايد وافضل مصدر هو معهد
دراسات الحرب الذي ينشر صور اقمار صناعيه
بصوره دوريه تحدد نقاط القتال ومناطق
القتال والمناطق التي تم السيطره عليها
هذا الجدل
حاره الروسيه عليها والتاكيد الروسي
السيطره عليها والنفي الاوكراني الامريكي
كذلك
بالسيطره الروسيه عليها في اي اطار يمكن
ان نقراه في اي سياق يمكن ان نقرا هذا
الجدل
يعني في جمله واحده الان
معهد دراسات الحرب اخر صوره اقمار صناعيه
تقريبا اشارت من خلال قراءه هذه الصور ان
60% من اجمالي المدينه شرق النهر وغرب
النهر تم السيطره عليه فيما لا يزال
القتال يدور حول الاربعين بالمئه المتبقي
اذا اخذنا هذا في الاطار الزمني للمعركه
وهي مقاربه غير دقيقه هناك ثمانيه اشهر
اذا يمكن تستمر في القتال لمده شهرين او
ثلاثه وهذا الامر لا يعتد به لان ظروف
المعركه تختلف من يوم لاخر بناء على
الموجودات للقوات المدافعه وقدره الجيش
الاوكراني على الامداد لكن حتى هذه اللحظه
لا استطيع ان اتبنى الموقف الروسي وحتى
الصيغه اللي استخدمت ان من وجهه نظر
قانونيه انا كما قائد عسكري لا يمكن ان
اعتمدها لماذا لانه انا اعتمد على مجريات
المعركه على ارض الواقع ومجريات المعركه
تقول ان اوكرانيا لا تزال تتمسك ب 40% من
مدينه فاقمت شكرا لك الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجيه كنت تبعنا من عمان
[موسيقى]